- De 3 à 3,5 %.
des cartes de crédit
augmente une fois de plus.
- Il faut être capable de payer
à chaque mois ce qu'il faut,
- Non, je suis contre
vraiment l'augmentation,
parce que je trouve qu'on
en paie déjà beaucoup.
ça va, mais si tout change de
0,5 %, 2 %, c'est là
où on voit vraiment l'impact
sur... puis les gens sont déjà
fait que c'est juste
supplémentaire,
le pouvoir d'achat diminue.
- Concrqu'est-ce que ça
change? Une personne avec
un solde de carte de crédit
du solde, ne devait rembourser
que 30 $ par mois.À 3,5 %, ellea
maintenant en rembourser 35,
soit une différence de 5 $temens
s'incrivent parmi les mesures
adoptées en 2017 par
l'Assemblée nationale
du Québec pour prélèmes d'endet.
Et les paiements mininumséeéeéee
en année de 0,5 point depourcen%
en 2025. Une hausse qui devrait
inciter les ménagettes, note cet
expert en insolvabilité.
- Je pense qu'en général,s.
C'est une forme d'épargne
obligatoire rembourser ses
dettes d'une façon plus rapide.
- Mais qui arrive à un momelusùu
les budgets sont déjà serrés.70,
s'orientent vers des
propositions au coembourser
leurs dettes.MICHEL THIBAULT, R,
syndic autorisé en insolvabi
- La classe moyenne, je dirais,
ont des dettes de crédit entre
qu'un paiement minimum à chaque
mois à 3-4 %, ça peut affe
leur budget au niveau
liquidités, mais ça les force
capital. Avant, quand c'était
2 %, les gens payaient
- Se tourner vers les
compagnies de cartes de crédit
solution à l'endettement
pour cette chercheuse.
EVE-LYNE COUTURIER,
chercheuse, IRIS
d'agir en forçant les compagnies
de cartes de crédit de
changer leurs comportements.
- D'ici là, certains préfèrent
paiement.
- J'ai comme peur de mes
dépenses, donc je fais très
attention à ça.
- Le paiement prévu pour toute
lui, reste inchangé;
au mininum de 5 %.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon